Ця зустріч зробила світ безпечнішим. Так підсумували переговори
Байдена і Путіна у газеті Süddeutsche Zeitung.
"Джо Байден не зганьбив Сполучені Штати, коли зустрівся з Володимиром Путіним
у Женеві... Перший висновок після Женеви полягає в тому, що у США
знову є президент, який не дозволить Путіну робити з себе дурня".
І російський лідер це зрозумів, пише Süddeutsche Zeitung.
"Не обов'язково внутрішня і зовнішня політика Путіна
в майбутньому стане менш агресивною і деструктивною. Але, щонайменше,
для нього змінюється розрахунок ціни, яку він повинен буде за це заплатити.
За Трампа ця ціна була нульовою. За Байдена буде вищою".
А Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung оприлюднила коментар під заголовком -
Пропозиція Байдена Путіну. На думку видання, саме за Путіна
"Росія пішла шляхом, який дедалі сильніше віддаляє її від демократичних держав".
"Байден протистоїть авторитарним режимам і пропонує діалог.
Одне - необхідно, інше - розумно, навіть якщо це приносить, як у Женеві,
лише маловідчутні результати", - пише видання.
"Ось так Байден хотів отримати зиск від зустрічі з Путіним" -
під таким заголовком вийшла стаття у виданні Handelsblatt.
"Представивши себе конструктивним співрозмовником у Женеві,
Байден вчергове протиставив себе Трампу, який свого часу зробив з зустрічі
з Путіним шоу", - пише Handelsblatt. "На тлі кібератак, конфлікту в Україні
й жорстокого переслідування критиків Путіна США не можуть
дозволити собі бути слабкими щодо Росії".
На тлі геополітичної напруженості останніх місяців вже саме по собі
проведення саміту за участі лідерів США і Росії
політики у Берліні сприйняли як добру новину.
Це треба вітати і це позитивний сигнал - сам факт того, що така зустріч відбулася.
Адже те, що ми бачили протягом останніх місяців – зокрема що стосується контактів
ЄС з Росією та контактів США з Росією - раз по раз було усвідомленням того,
що існує дефіцит діалогу. Однак якщо хтось багато очікував від нинішньої зустрічі,
то він був, напевно, розчарований. Звичайно, треба розуміти,
що це була перша зустріч нового американського президента з Володимиром Путіним
і ключовий результат цього діалогу - дуже позитивний результат -
повернення послів. Але я б не вдавалася ейфорії з приводу перших подібних контактів.
Депутати Бундестагу наголошують й на тому, що Байден перед зустріччю
з Путіним погодив свої позиції з Великою сімкою.
Я вважаю, що меседж Путіну був чітким.
Джо Байден - прихильник мультилатеральних рішень і прихильник співпраці з друзями.
Думаю, що він говорив Путіну те, що обговорювалося на саміті Великої сімки.
Німецькі парламентарії сподіваються, що за зустріччю в Женеві буде продовження -
у вигляді двосторонніх контактів з найширшого кола питань.
Цей аспект, з мого погляду, вкрай важливий.
А саме те, що теми переговорів були дуже сильно сфокусовані
на спільних інтересах: кіберзлочинність, боротьба з тероризмом,
а також на сферах інтересів у Сирії та Лівії. І тут - особливо у сфері
кіберзлочинності, у питанні контролю над озброєннями та про заходи
щодо зміцнення довіри - можна було б тепер говорити
на рівні експертів, військових і політиків.
У Берліні також наголошують на важливості теми захисту прав людини,
яку Байден порушив на переговорах з Путіним.
Особисто я привітала той факт, що американський президент
порушив тему прав людини, причому дуже чітко. Різниця між попередником
Дональдом Трампом і Джо Байденом стала завдяки цьому дуже ясною.
Депутати зазначають, що зовнішньополітичні ініціативи Байдена
набувають особливої ​​важливості на тлі майбутньої зміни канцлера у Німеччині.
Для багатьох оглядачів головним успіхом зустрічі Байдена і Путіна
став сам факт того, що вона відбулася, а також те, що цього разу,
на відміну від розмови Трампа і Путіна в Гельсінкі три роки тому,
все не перетворилося на спектакль. Президентам, вважають експерти,
вдалося поговорити по суті.
Я трохи боявся, що один з них або обидва можуть вийти через годину
після початку зустрічі і сказати, що все це не має жодного сенсу.
Не варто забувати, що зустріч проходила на тлі погіршення відносин.
Тому, насправді, дивно те, що була - не скажу, що гармонія, але, тим не менше,
помітна взаємна терпимість і навіть повага.
Байден, на відміну від Обами, не називав Росію "регіональної силою",
а також не став знову повторювати, що Путін - убивця.
Путін також з повагою відгукнувся про свого колегу.
Путін хотів цієї зустрічі, для нього було важливо, щоб його сприймали
на одному рівні з американським президентом. Байден повинен був провести цю зустріч.
До цього він зустрічався з лідерами інших країн в межах саміту Великої сімки,
ЄС і НАТО. І Путін був останнім пунктом програми його подорожі до Європи,
яка мала на меті після тієї катастрофи для американської зовнішньої політики,
якою було правління Трампа, повернутися до нормальних відносин,
і це включає в себе діалог з Росією.
Саміт Путіна і Байдена потрібно сприймати саме в контексті
повернення США на світову арену, вважає і Крістіан Гаке.
Першою частиною цього стали зустрічі з партнерами по НАТО і ЄС.
Другою - саме налагодження відносин з Росією, з тим щоб сконцентруватися
на головному питанні зовнішньої політики США.
Ми побачимо це вже у найближчі місяці, і це - відносини з Китаєм.
Китай - це та сама проблема, яка для всіх очевидна, але яку вважали
за краще не згадувати. І через це зустріч у Женеві, з точки зору американців,
мала запобігти зближенню Росії та Китаю.
Крім Китаю, оглядачі відзначили ще одну тему,
якої у своїх пресконференціях після переговорів президенти
торкнулися лише побіжно - це ситуація в Україні та Білорусі.